it's great to welcome back to the
program today Dylan Burns Dylan is a
streamer and an aspiring War journalist
currently with an emphasis on Ukraine he
joins us from Ukraine now uh so Dylan
how how long have you been in Ukraine
off and on now
uh in total about a year now I came over
first uh in late April of last year I
spent uh most of that year or at least
half of that year over in Ukraine before
heading back over for the holidays to
spend time with family and I've been
over here again since March to film with
the mining Crews interview soldiers who
have fought in Bach Moot and uh in bed
with people on the front line who have
been delivering Aid to civilians in need
so one of the claims that different
folks are making uh uh is that the death
toll in Ukraine is not being accurately
represented I mean there's people on the
political left that have said this
Donald Trump has said this do you have
any insight into that I guess just
generally
so a lot of the estimates that people go
off of are the official un estimates and
I'm going to be honest I've only seen
the UN once since I've been here on the
ground the UN are not very visible when
it comes to Frontline communities in the
areas that are most seen death and
destruction and the UN also does not
have access to a lot of communities that
have seen the worst of the violence this
war has brought to Ukraine they don't
have rental ready and available access
to locations like a mariopal or uh for
example Bachman cities that have seen
high amounts of Civilian casualties
maryopal especially and the Russians
have done a lot of work to cover up
their tracks people saw as they
evacuated Kiev how the soldiers were
trying to burn bodies in order to cover
up exactly what happened in the torture
and the uh summary executions that were
going on in their quote unquote
cleansing operation that's the word they
used in private Communications to
describe what they were doing in the key
of oblast not the word I used so I do
think that the uh death toll is horribly
underestimated by how much I don't know
but most estimates that I've seen that
are more serious seems to have the
civilian death toll
um much much higher than the 8 to 10 to
15 000 that the UN is estimating at this
point we're talking more in the um like
hundreds of thousands um or at least
over a hundred thousand okay so that's
that's dramatically different and
dramatically more tragic
um the estimations vary of course of
course of course the demining talk a
little bit about what this is what are
these minds and where what what are the
origins of those minds and what is the
demining operation
so recently I spent a month embedded
with d minors in the heart of oblast and
operating liberated territory mostly I
was with them as they tried to remove
mines that were you know anti-personnel
mines uh um pmf ones which are butterfly
mines which the Soviets use heavily in
Afghanistan uh anti-tank mines the pmf
ones are are notorious in the way that
they don't really look like a normal
mind they actually look kind of like a
toy and so in Afghanistan Afghan
children used to be known to pick them
up thinking they were a toy before
losing their entire arm losing their leg
and they're scattered over a lot of
Civilian areas in this war and they have
been scattered uh both in Russian
occupied territory and you and you in
territory that's controlled by the
Ukrainian government and in the time
that I spent with those D minors in the
Arc of oblast
um not only the deminers in our area die
but also civilians died in our area from
these mines and there was only around
one specific small city in the
harkheville loss and this is happening
all over territories that were occupied
by the Russians anywhere that is
liberated has to be meticulously cleared
by D miners afterwards but the amount of
explosives that we're working with we're
talking about 70 to 100 years of
demining work post-war the 70-year
estimate by the way I was told four
months ago if the war stopped
immediately wow so it's probably worse
than uh current estimates once this is
all over it'll probably be much worse
are they are they more in rural areas
where they can be hidden or in what
sorts of places are they
they're in all types of locations
they're in a lot of farms and farm
Fields right they place a lot of
anti-tank mines there because they were
the Russians were scared that there
would be a counter-offensive that could
punch through those fields there's a lot
of anti-personnel Minds in the force
that I've been in
um again I was filming near power lines
that needed to be restored so they could
bring power to local communities and I
saw mon 50 mines which are basically
like American Claymores I saw pmf ones
and densely populated communities and as
we were driving by
um with these D minors through these
Villages and doing work many many on
many occasions civilians would run out
to the demining crews and uh almost beg
them to come to their homes and remove
the mines that are literally in their
backyard and we're talking
anti-personnel anti-tank many of which
are booby traps so civilians and D
minors may have a much harder time
removing them what is the process for
removing such a mind for removing
um it depends on the mind if if it's um
an anti-personnel mine like a mon 50 I
did record
um uh much of the process and actually
uploaded it on Twitter if people wanted
to go check it out
um uh usually you have to
um for example I'm on 50 every mine's
different you have to identify where the
tripwire is you need to cut the tripwire
before going to the Detonator and
removing the Detonator but the problem
is That's supposed to be the official
process that's how you're supposed to do
it but many of these minds are booby
trapped so that when you go through this
official process if you don't notice the
other tripwires or the other mines that
are attached to it it can go off and
kill the demanding crew when I was in
the harkivoplast we actually lost some
sesu workers emergency service workers
to anti-tank mines that were booby
trapped there was one anti-tank bind but
under it there were four other anti-tank
mines creating an incredible explosion
that killed some of our guys over there
what's what's the radius at which these
these things are dangerous
it depends on the mind if we're talking
like a butterfly mine it's only going to
be like maybe like 10 15 feet but if
we're talking anti-tank mines it's going
to be much greater distance which can
injure and maim and kill a lot more
people and how many minds are put
together right because if again it was
five anti-tank mines so that can kill a
lot of people
there are social media videos that are
released and I don't know what point
people are trying to make with some of
these videos but I've just seen the
videos and the videos are of almost like
idyllic coffee shop scenes in different
parts of Ukraine and I don't know if the
argument that's trying to be made is
lots of people are ignoring what's going
on and just going about their lives or
certain parts of the country are
completely safe and this is only
affecting part of the country can you
talk a little bit about whether this
dichotomy does exist and whether there
are Parts where it is just business as
usual hipster coffee shops and flat
whites
sure so most of these videos originate
in Kiev I've seen a lot of them where
it's like oh here is like a coffee shop
in Kiev or Club in Kiev yeah and if you
would compare what it's like to being
kiev for example Bach moot obviously the
living standard is going to be much
different it's not on directly to front
line they cannot be shelled directly by
Russian Artillery which was a major
contributor to a lot of you civilian
casualties in harkiv when the Russian
Artillery guns were in front of harkiv
they constantly shelved the city in my
opinion I think it was a deliberate Act
of Revenge due to the fact that they
couldn't take the city and they took a
lot of casualties trying to take the
city
um and so when those artillery guns are
pushed back that does save a lot of
Civilian lives but most if not all of
Ukraine is in range of Russian cruise
missiles
um the S 300 missiles that they kind of
retrofit to be used that's just like
rockets to like lob them at the city
they're not terribly accurate but the
point isn't to be accurate the point is
to whittle down Ukraine's air defense
the point and in my opinion is the
terrorized civilian population and even
though I'm in the supposedly trampled
key of in fact I'm even in a more
tranquil part of Kiev because I'm not in
the city itself I'm in the countryside
but um last week live on stream a
missile passed a few hundred feet over
our home uh and it was caught on stream
I had to end stream because of it so
every part in of Ukraine could be
hypothetically bombed by the Russians at
any time and that's why I think air
defense is so important to protect
civilian lives and I can tell you since
the Patriot air defense has been here in
the key of oblast it has been busy can
you talk about you you had a situation
where a Russian drone spotted you can
you talk about that
sure
um during my last trip while I was here
my first front line in bed I was going
to hang out with the zaparosa
territorial defense as they went to the
Ford operating position that means the
last position until the Russians it was
about one to maybe one and a half mile
from the Russians the Ford operating
position we were going to
um I was going there in what was the
equivalent of a soccer mom van painted
green that was constantly breaking down
but
um that's of course due to the fact that
territorial defense their local
Defenders and they don't have a lot of
times the best equipment as much as you
always see like the tanks and everything
in the foreign media much of that
equipment has still yet to arrive in
Ukraine and much of that equipment um is
is being used by uh is being stored in
their in their waiting to use it in the
counter offensive and so not everybody
has the best equipment and the situation
has improved since since I've been with
them and I did this as well but on the
way to the front line
um we were told that the position was
getting shelled so we had to get out of
the van and we just kind of hanged out
on the side of the road and then I heard
this just like weird buzzing sound like
30 minutes and just just kind of waiting
on the side of the road like your phone
vibrates or maybe like a small swarm of
bees and I look to my friend and
colleague Patrick hillsman and I asked
him like what do you hear that and he
says I don't hear it I'm like okay
whatever then five seconds later
somebody else drone we all have to run
into the forest hide there for like
three to four minutes nobody knows if
it's a suicide drone nobody knows if it
has like a grenade attached to it which
is going to drop on us we or if it's a
spotter drone that's spotting Ford
Hillary right so then the decision is
made that we have to run for it we run
into the soccer mom van get in drive a
few miles uh away before parking back
into the forest to try to rethink a plan
on where to go next
um after 15 minutes my friend Patrick
hillsman is adamant that the artillery
we heard in the distance was our former
position getting shelled well I never
confirmed it but he's adamant that
that's what he uh that's what happened
uh once we were we decided that you know
it's too dangerous to be in the this
area we get into soccer mom van again
they try to start it it breaks down so
we're there for another five minutes
just hoping to get the soccer mom van
you know back and running again we jump
in it finally you know gets running and
we go off to SPG nine practice
um I'm happy the soccer mom fans started
yeah to say the least
um Dylan have you needed medical
attention I don't mean from injuries
sustained while doing this stuff but I
just mean like you've been there a year
have you needed to Avail yourself of any
kind of doctors or the medical system
there and if so what was that like
no I've I've thankfully I've never had
to get medical attention there's been a
few times where we've been uh near
somebody when they got hurt and we had
to apply first aid to them when we were
in the Don bass specifically uh
chromatous which is a major location the
Russians have been bombing and trying to
capture we were with an elderly woman at
a dog shelter I think actually the only
functioning dog shelter in uh the city
which has since been bombed since we
were there
um there was somebody who needed medical
attention but I have never needed it the
closest I've needed it is when watching
like Tucker talk about it you know like
maybe in an aspirin or something okay
got it
um what's the plan for how long to stay
there and and when to come home
so I don't know exactly for me I kind of
I want to keep filming until I feel like
I've I've gotten enough
um I know I want to be home for
Christmas but I'm probably going to be
here again next year as well I want to
keep covering this war until all major
hostilities have ceased uh I think that
it deserves the coverage there is a
million different stories to tell and I
want to make sure that people can't lie
about the type of disgusting that's
going on here
wow uh Dylan Burns in Ukraine streaming
oh by the way the streams are they at 6
PM Eastern but you're there so like are
you streaming in the middle of the night
Ukraine time is that what's going on I'm
streaming I'm streaming from 1am to late
late streams and why that's
I I want to concentrate on making sure
that this message gets to an American
audience because
as much as I do have Ukrainian viewers
and my Ukrainian audience has certainly
grown since I've been covering here yeah
um the main I don't need to tell
ukrainians that their country uh is
being torn apart I don't need to tell
you ukrainians or explain to them the
importance of air defense they
understand it they understand it more
better than anybody else in the world
sure if there's any audience that needs
this message it's the American public
who are constantly being lied to uh
about either the oh the war is not as
serious as they say or the war crimes
aren't as bad as it is or oh you know
it's not really that important or uh you
know or for example Tucker Carlson line
about the seven to one numbers for every
one Ukrainian uh for everyone Russian
that died seven ukrainians uh in the
military died these this that's the
audience I want to aim at because that's
the audience that it's being lied to
because uh the Russians want to undercut
American support in America for for
Ukraine so they can trample across the
country loot pillage and Conquer it
Dylan really appreciate the work you're
doing and stay stay safe and let's talk
again
thank you very much you have a fantastic
day